it was a dark time for Star Wars when CG
characters started popping into every
corner of the series but before Jorge
Arce stumbled into our collective
consciousness
Star Wars was all about puppets which
brings us to this guy I'm Dave Barclay
I'm a puppeteer and puppet builder and
animatronic effects supervisor
you might recognize Dave better under
200 pounds of fiberglass and latex
because he was one of the puppeteers
inside Jabba the Hutt but to play the
most notorious gangster on Tatooine you
got to start somewhere and Dave well he
got his big break with a little green
man Yoda was famously puppeteered by
Frank Oz the legend behind Cookie
Monster and Grover but Yoda was a
complicated puppy and it took four to
five people working different body parts
to bring him to life Dave's job was
controlling Yoda's eyes and ears there's
a sequence when Yoda is flooding mark
with a stick saying where he was what he
was doing and I'm doing a little squint
and subtle control on the eyes yep right
there that's me doing the eyes there
towards the end of the filming on Empire
Strikes Back Frank Oz was performing
Yoda and it became clear he had to move
on to another film and he wasn't going
to be available so they needed someone
to take over from Yoda and Frank
nominated me I was 19 years old so
suddenly there I am with with Yoda even
at 19 years old
Dave's Yoda scenes blended perfectly
with Frank Oz
that was d did you guys see that let's
take one more Dave did such a good job
they called him back and asked him to
run a new puppet call jabba the hutt
jabba the hutt was probably the most
complicated and sophisticated
animatronic puppet that anyone had ever
tried to build and it took six to seven
people to operate inside Jabba was very
claustrophobic very close one person
doing the left-hand the head movement in
the tongue another puppeteer doing the
mechanical tail another puppeteer doing
the breathing on the air bladders I did
Jabba's right hand and I did his jaw and
then I provided the voice on stage my
voice doesn't make it to scream but if
you've turned up on set will hear this
sort of voice where's my dog as a child
they weren't really any movies that had
puppeteers in them there was a little
bit here and there but there were no
solid characters like Yoda and being
part of the Yoda team which really was
the first performance animatronic in
movies was the start of this huge growth
that lasted about twenty years and as a
puppeteer and the puppet maker and
someone who loves the movies it was I
was in there exactly the right place at
the right time and have had a wonderful
career doing what I adore so I feel very
lucky and privileged
[Music]